az ételnek azt mondod hogy van egy
identitása erről egy kicsit tudnál
beszélni bővebben hogy mit értesz
identitás alatt mert a laikus ember
számára az egy flekken kirakva
krumplival mi mi az identitása van egy
ételnek ha éppenséggel be akarok nevezni
vagy egy egy ételt el akarok készíteni
például próbába akkor igyekszem
megcélozni egy
vendégkört ahhoz az ételt is úgy
készítem el hogy annak olyan identitása
legyen hogy egészség legyen gyönyörű
szép tálalásban technológiákat vigyünk
bele és mégis ragaszkodjunk a
hagyományainkhoz tehát identitásban én
inkább azt mondanám hogy arra figyelek
oda hogy úgy alkalmazzak technológiákat
és úgy készítsem el az ételt hogy a
miénk legyen de mégis a vendég totálisan
a magáinak érezze minden egyes
mozzanatát az egész ételnek